[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERGUS HURLEY: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to the 10 secrets to
be able to increase your user
retention of your application.
I'm Fergus Hurley,
product manager
at Google focused on improving
the quality of the Android
ecosystem.
JOE CASTORENA:
I'm Joe Castorena.
I'm with the Google
Play BD team.
RICCARDO GOVONI: And I'm
Ricardo, engineering manager
in Google Play.
So today we're going to
spend some time together
to understand how the
Play Console can help
you create great apps
that captivate your users
and achieve great
user retention.
To do that, we're going to spend
a good amount of time thinking
about performance.
We're going to have a
focus on app performance
and technical quality,
and we're going
to look at how you
can achieve that
throughout your app lifecycle.
Finally, we're
going to look at how
Play is going to
reward all of you
as developers for focusing
on app performance
and technical quality.
First, so why we'll
focus on app performance?
Why does it matter?
And the reason is pretty simple.
Some people say that there
is an app for everything.
The thing is there is
not a high-performing
app for everything, and
high-performing apps
achieve great and
high user retention.
And that's why
performance matters.
A high-quality app that doesn't
crash and doesn't stutter
is critical to achieve
that high user retention.
Users love these
great experiences,
and they have no reason
to leave when they
have a great-performing app.
For US developers, it's a great
differentiator from other apps
that may offer similar
functionality to yours.
A couple of numbers
that you may have seen--
we have shown them
earlier today--
but here is some
data points that
suggest why creating a
high-quality app matters.
Summarizing, if you create
an app that doesn't really
perform that well, users
are going to notice,
and they're going to
mention it in their reviews.
Other users are going
to see it, and it
is going to spread around.
When we look at reviews that
have been written in the Play
Store, 50% of the time
people left a one star,
they were mentioning
stability and bugs in the app.
60% of the time they were
leaving you five stars,
it was because you focused
on speed, usability, design,
and all these great things.
We asked a few
developers around,
and here is one that we
also showed yesterday.
Busuu, which is a
language learning
app which is used worldwide,
made a big, big investment
on performance.
It's part of their culture.
And with that focus and focusing
on the technical performance
of their app, they
improved their star rating
from 4.1 to 4.5 stars,
which is a pretty big jump
if you think about it.
So we're going to focus and walk
through a few features on how--
There we go--
Focus on a few
features that are going
to help you create high-quality
apps throughout the lifecycle
of your development, from
before the launch to when you're
about to go live to
when you are fully live
and you want to understand and
iterate your app performance.
And these are going
to be our 10 secrets.
So the first one I am going
to mention, before launch,
is the pre-launch report.
We mentioned it
today in the keynote.
It's in the Play section.
Pre-launch report
summarizes issues
that we found when testing
your app automatically
against a collection of
physical Android devices.
We think that it is already
greatly contributing
to the success of apps, and
already thousands of developers
are using that.
Pre-launch report
behind the scene
is powered by the Firebase
Test Lab for Android.
It's basically our data center
packed full of Android devices
where you can test your app.
Pre-launch report
does it automatically.
If you want to you do your own
custom testing, custom scripts,
and such, you can integrate
with the Firebase Test
Lab for Android and run
your own custom scripts
against physical devices
from Android Studio,
from your continuous
build, and such.
A key part of pre-launch
report that you
can find in the
Play Console is what
we call app stability testing.
We have a robot crawler that
automatically crawls and plays
with your app for
every APK that you
upload to the alpha or beta
channel in the Play Console.
It crawls the app
automatically for five minutes,
and it tells you if it
detects any it crashes.
And you get the little
red indications there.
Which means that if the
robot detects a crash when
your APK was in
alpha or beta, it's
a crash that didn't
reach production,
because you can then fix it
before your app goes to prod.
And your users will not
leave a one-star review
because of that.
A vast majority of
Play top developers
have adopted the Play
pre-launch report
since when we
launched it last year.
And since then, we've performed
over 6.5 million crawls
over hundred and
thousands of APKs.
These numbers are
nice, but the best one
is the impact for users.
85% of the time when the
pre-launch report detected
a crash, the app was not then
later launched to production.
And this means that
millions of users
have been spared from
a crash that would
have otherwise affected them.
The first big change
and announcement that we
are making today is this one.
You may have heard, obviously,
about Android O and the latest
developer preview and such.
So we took a bunch
of Pixel phones,
and along with other devices,
we made them available to you
in the pre-launch report.
You can now test very
easily how your app performs
on Android O. You just have
to upload an APK to the alpha
or beta channel in
the Play Console,
and by the end of this talk
or by the end of tonight's
dinner or the concert,
you get the result back,
and you get to see how
your app performed when
executing against Android O.
So this was secret number one--
Android O preview available
in the pre-launch report
for all of you starting now.
Second secret is more
pre-launch report features.
Not only we add more
devices, we invest also
in the functionality
that it offers.
To allow the robot to
crawl more of your app
with data that you
control, you can now
specify test credentials
that the robot will
use to pass through
login screens
and explore more of your app
behind those login screens.
We have improved the way the
robot captures screenshots
and videos during the crawl.
Specifically, we now
take into account
the structure of your
app, the activities
that it is composed of, and
the transition they're in
to cross the screenshots
intelligently.
So you get to see
at a glance how
your different parts of
the app look and feel,
which is useful if you
want to spot-- if you have,
for example, visual
inconsistencies
across form factors
or across languages.
And finally, we also
automatically scan
your app for vulnerabilities
and privacy leaks.
We added a bunch of
scans and new detectors
over the last year.
So now we capture
up to, I think,
30 different types of
vulnerabilities and privacy
issues, be it the usage
of outdated libraries
that have known problems
or be it coding patterns
that you have that result
in leaking identifiers.
So if you have not
already given it a try,
you can go to the
Play Console now,
opt in to the pre-launch
report, and the next APK
you will upload
to alpha and beta
will undergo all these
treatments and analysis.
A number of developers like
Paul, CEO of Playdemic,
have found that
it's really helpful
to give them that
sense of security
to go to production safely.
So definitely consider
giving it a try.
And so this is secret
number two, more features
in the pre-launch report.
The next step is you're
about to go live,
and you have to make
distribution decisions.
The moment when
you go live is one
of the most critical in your
app lifecycle because this
is when your users
will discover your app
or your new features
for the first time.
And Android today gives
you an amazing reach thanks
to the diversity of Android
devices, cross-capabilities,
and price points.
But we heard from many of you
that navigating the device
space and the targeting
the right devices
can be a bit of a challenge.
And so we have made
a number of changes.
As you may have
heard yesterday, we
have created a brand new device
catalog in the Play Console.
You go from the long
list of checkboxes
that you have on the one side
to a full-featured device
catalog across the thousands
of devices that you can target.
It's not just nice to look at.
There is a bunch of things
that it can do for you.
First, for each device,
you get full device specs--
RAM, GPU, system on
chip, screen size,
OS version and everything.
We also group the different SKUs
that belong to the same model
so you can see all the
common devices in one go.
You can search by spec.
You can search, for example,
for all devices that
have a given characteristic,
like having at least a couple
of gigs of RAM.
And for every search or
slice that you create,
we tell you how
many installations,
which rating, and
how much revenue
is coming from that
particular slice.
What do you use that for?
Use that for what we call
device exclusion rules.
You can now choose to target
your application to a selection
of devices under your control.
For example, if you're
developing a rich graphics
game, you may choose to
target only devices that
have at least one
gigabyte of RAM
because that is the minimum
under which your game will
run satisfactorily.
You can also set similar
exclusion rules-- for example,
on System-on-Chip
because maybe you
have detected a particular
issue with a System-on-Chip,
and you want to temporarily
limit distribution
to those devices
until you get a fix,
and you can resume
distributing to those.
Whenever you create
an exclusion rule,
we tell you exactly how
many users, how much rating,
and how much revenue
is going to be affected
by excluding those devices.
So you can make this
decision consciously
and know whether it's
worth doing it or not.
Finally, we've updated the
Play Console throughout.
So from many different
places in the Play Console
you can link straight
into device catalog,
be it from reviews, be it from
the stats pages, and such.
So this is secret number three,
a brand new device catalog
and targeting capabilities.
The last one that I
want to mention briefly,
and you may have heard in
a session earlier today,
is a brand new
release dashboard.
Until now, looking at
statistics in the Play Console
was a bit sad because you've got
limited analytics capabilities.
And they only
updated once a day,
and sometimes it
would take two days.
So we decided to
change that a lot.
You get the brand
new release dashboard
and associated statistics
that update by the hour
and capture all the
significant information that
describe your
application status,
be it crashes, ratings,
installation, and installations
as they happen.
So you can monitor your releases
while they are in progress.
For key information like
ratings and crashes and reviews,
they come in real time.
So you can detect the
moment your release goes out
if there is a problem coming,
and you can take action
immediately.
And so this was number
four, a brand new,
real-time monitoring
dashboard for your releases.
Fergus?
FERGUS HURLEY: Yes?
RICCARDO GOVONI: Yours.
FERGUS HURLEY: Thank you.
Great.
So we've talked about before
release, during release.
Now we're going to talk about
the data from the field,
and how you can
be able how to use
that to be able to improve the
quality of your application.
The first area to talk
about here is reviews.
So we relaunched reviews
analysis last year
at Google I/O. This
enabled you to be
able to see what topics
people are talking
about in your reviews
and how those topics are
having a positive
or negative impact
on your rating in the store.
This is where we're putting
Google's machine learning team
to work for you, to be able
to extract those topics
and be able to also see
how you're comparing
with other apps in your category
with the peer benchmarks
that we offer.
Now, up until today, it was
only available in English.
Now we're making it available
in the second most popular
language on Google
Play, which is Spanish.
Another major market for
Play developers is Japan,
so we're also enabling
you to be able to see
the topics that people are
talking about in Japanese.
One of the big
limitations that people
have had with interacting
with users on Google Play
and responding to reviews
is that we haven't
had a full review history.
When a user would
update their review,
you wouldn't be able to see the
previous review that they've
written.
Now we're enabling
it to be able to see
the full thread of the history
of any communication you've had
and they have had with
you in our review section.
If a user deletes
their whole review,
you won't see the
history, of course.
But if they keep
changing their review,
you can be able to have a fluid
conversation with them now.
Developers have been getting
great results from reviews.
We've seen a 50% increase in the
number of developer responses
over the past year.
And the reason they're
doing that and interacting
with reviews is because they
see users increasing their star
rating as a result. We now
have an updated rating section
in the Play Console
where you can
be able to see what is
the change in rating
that users are doing
if you reply to them,
and what is the change in rating
if you haven't replied to them.
And you can be able to
make the decision yourself
as to whether this is a wise
investment of your time to be
able to respond to reviews.
Finally, the last big
addition to the reviews area
that we're announcing
today is the ability
to be able to flag reviews.
So we do a lot of evaluation
on the reviews when
they're posted on Google Play.
Sometimes, reviews that don't
match our posting guidelines
get through our evaluation.
And if you think that
one of the reviews
does not match our posting
guidelines that you
can be able to let
us know, and we'll
do another manual review and
evaluation of that review
and determine whether we
should remove it or not.
This is already--
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So this has already been
rolled out to a few developers,
and it will be rolled out
to all the Play developers
over the next couple of months.
So stay tuned for that.
So that's the fifth secret,
reviews and focusing
on your reviews and
the reviews analysis
and reviews management tools
that we have available to you.
Now let's jump into
the sixth secret,
which is Android vitals.
Android vitals was featured
in the keynote yesterday.
It's a big initiative
at Google to be
able to improve the stability
and performance of apps
across the whole
Android ecosystem.
The first thing we're doing
is focusing on three core
performance areas.
Those are stability,
render time, and battery.
However, you'll see a lot
more performance areas
being provided to you over
the course of the next year.
We just launched the
Android vitals section
in the Play Developer Console.
This is where you
can go and see today
the data on your
application from the users
who have opted in.
So where does this
data come from?
This data is generated from
the hundreds of millions
of users who have opted-in
to share their device usage
and diagnostics data with
Google and our partners, you.
So we are now making
that available to you
for the first time.
And we're very excited for you
to be able to use this data
and improve your
apps as a result.
You do not need to use
an SDK to get this data.
You do not need to
change your app at all.
You just need to go to
the Play Developer Console
and look at this data.
Now, we're going to be making
a lot of data available here
for the first time,
and we think this
is going to change the
dynamics within companies
in terms of how they
look at performance.
Up until now, very few
people within the company
have seen the performance
data on their application
because they aren't running
Android Studio themselves
and looking at performance data.
Now that we're exposing
that in the Play Console,
your product manager, your other
engineers that you work with
can be able to see
that data and can
be able to make the choice
of whether you should
invest in improving performance
or building that latest
feature.
Now, to make it really
actionable for you,
we have generated this
concept of bad behaviors.
This is where, if
you're in the bottom 25%
for any one of these metrics,
we will flag that to you
and put a red exclamation
mark on your application.
This alerts you that this is
an area where you should really
invest in because you're
underperforming compared
to your peers.
So this talk is
about user retention,
and here's a quote from
the Kabam team of how much
user retention has improved
as a result of them
focusing on performance.
And so we hope that
all of you will
make performance a big
part of your culture
and your app development
for us in the future.
Great.
So now we're going to jump
into three other secrets that
are all tied together, and I'm
going to draw an analogy here
to triathlons.
I completed a couple
of triathlons myself.
And when you are
training for a triathlon
and you improve in one sport
and you increase your fitness,
you increase your performance
into other sports as well.
And that's where, by improving
in one performance area,
you'll probably see
performance improvements
in the other areas.
But you still need the
knowledge and equipment
to be successful in
each one individually.
So I hope you'll connect
with the analogy.
So let's jump into
the first sport--
only joking-- the first
app performance area here.
So stability.
So stability is all about
providing a reliable experience
to users, and we are
providing a lot of insights
here that you
might not have been
able to get from other
crash reporting tools.
And why would you
care about this area?
So what we found is that making
a first impression on users
is critical, as we all know,
and that the data shows
that if your app crashes a
lot on the first day of use,
you get 30% more uninstallations
than if your app works well.
So really focusing on
these stability issues
is critical to your user base.
As I mentioned, this data
from the Android Vitals
is from users who have opted in.
Previously, the data that has
been in the crashes and ANRs
section of the Play
Console has come from users
individually reporting events.
Now that we have this data
from the opted-in users,
you can expect to see about
100x increase in the crash
data in the Play Console.
So that could give you
a lot better coverage
and a lot better insights
into your app performance
while still covering
98% of Android versions.
Now, I'm sure all of you
are aware of the crashes
and crash per user rate and
all that sort of things.
ANRs are a critical thing to
focus on on Android as well.
An ANR is an application
not responding.
This is when your
application is frozen
for more than five seconds.
In the Android
vitals section, we
show you broken
down by app version,
by device, and by Android
version what is your ANR rate.
Then you can click on,
let's say, the ANRs
from a specific app
version, and you
can be able to go in and
see all the ANR clusters
corresponding to that version.
And you can be able
to then go in, click
on a specific cluster, and be
able to view the thread dumps
and other diagnostics
information about the devices,
et cetera, to be able to really
focus on fixing that issue.
You can also be able to
access the previous data
source that we had for ANRs
and crashes in the Play Console
if you'd like to see
that data as well.
Twitter has built a
phenomenal application.
It has an amazing,
reliable experience.
However, they were even
able to learn things
from the ANR data
in the Play Console
when we gave them
early access to this,
and they were able
to fix issues already
with their application
as a result.
So I encourage you all to go
and check out this section
and see what you can fix.
To recap in the
stability area, we
have two core things to focus
on here, reducing your ANR rate
and reducing your crash rate.
Next we're going to
jump into rendering.
So rendering is about
providing a fluid experience
to your users and
having it so that they
feel like they're getting a 60
frames per second experience
on their device.
60 frames per second
results in draw events
happening every 16 milliseconds.
So if you miss one of
these draw events your app
starts to feel laggy.
Even if you miss it by
just one millisecond,
then you've missed
that frame and it
appears at 32 milliseconds
until that frame is redrawn.
If you miss multiple
events, then it really
appears like it's a slow
experience for the users.
And the app has
nearly even become
frozen to a lesser
extent than an ANR,
but still not responding
to their input.
And this is about 700
milliseconds is what we found.
We now give you the
insights into this data
in the Play Console in
terms of render times.
We show you the distribution
of render times.
And we show you the
potential root causes
of why these things
are happening
so you can be able
to figure out if it's
something to do with things
happening on the UI thread.
The two core metrics to look
at in terms of render time
are slow rendering
and frozen frames.
So slow rendering is
when the percentage
of users who experience more
than 50% of their frames
rendered at greater
than 16 milliseconds.
Frozen frames is when 0.1% of
the frames out of your render
rate are greater than
700 milliseconds.
Great.
So now we've covered
the eight secrets.
We're going to jump
into the ninth secret
here now, which is battery.
So we all want to be able
to have battery life last
for the entire day, and
we all as app developers
want to reduce our usage on the
battery when it's unnecessary.
And this is where we're now
going to start telling you
when we think you
are actually using
the battery unnecessarily.
This includes using
the radios and the CPU.
The first one is wake locks.
This is where, when
the device is idle,
you're keeping a wake lock
for more than an hour.
In the Android vitals
section, each metric
that I'm talking about
for the bad behaviors
here has a separate way for
you to be able to diagnose
and investigate the data.
For the wake locks, we provide
you the wake lock name.
And you can be
able to figure out
where there is an issue there
with a specific wake lock
and go and investigate
that specific one.
We also link out from each
of the performance areas
to articles on the
developer.android.com
documentation so you can be
able to understand each one
of these wake locks as well.
The wake locks that you use
within in your application
should not be completely
unique per user
because otherwise you
won't be able to get
the aggregated view of them.
We also have it broken
down by app version,
as you can see
here, and then you
can be able to see the
distribution of wake locks.
Finally, the last metric that
we're introducing is wakeups.
So wakeups are when
you are constantly
waking up the device
when the device is idle.
So we flag your application
when you wake the application up
more than 10 times
per hour, and you
have a high percentage of
users who are impacted by that.
This is another tab
within the console.
We give you the wakeup
tag names here as well,
so you can be able to figure
out where the issue is.
The two battery
areas to look at,
stuck wake locks and
excessive wakeups.
I encourage you to check
those out and figure out
where you are having an issue
in your application potentially.
And as I said, we'll flag
you with a red marker
if you're in the
bottom 25% of apps
for each one of
these metrics so you
know to look into that area.
We're now going to hand
over to Joe to reveal--
actually, one sec.
I've got some bonus action
secrets for you guys,
just on the Android vitals side.
So we have many resources
outside of the Play Console
to help you with improving
your performance.
The first one is to use
developer.android.com.
Tons of documentation on the
performance areas in general.
Tons of videos, and
from the Play Console
we link out to the
relevant ones as well.
Next is to use Android
Studio Profilers that
have been built into
Android Studio 3.0, which
was launched yesterday.
And finally, Firebase
Performance Monitoring
is an SDK that you can
include in your application
so that you don't just need
to look over the whole APK.
We can diagnose specifically
within your APK,
within a specific part of the
APK, if there is an issue.
And you can be
able to instrument
to the application yourself.
Out of the box comes
network and startup time.
But there are
counters, so you're
going to be able to set it
up whatever way you'd like.
Now we're going to hand it over
to Joe for the final secret
on rewards.
JOE CASTORENA: All right, it's
now time for the best part.
[APPLAUSE]
So why should you care?
Why should you jump on this now?
Well, reducing your
one-star ratings,
reducing your
uninstalls, those seem
like pretty compelling reasons.
Those, in addition to the
things that Ricardo alluded
to earlier like getting a more
stable app leading to better
user experience, leading to
stronger engagement, longer
retention, all these
are really good reasons.
But there's actually
directly impactful reasons
that relate to your
app and its presence
and its performance
in the Play Store.
This relates to Play's
perceived quality of your app
and the promotability
that goes with it.
Play has always strived to
surface the highest quality
apps for our users, and your
app health is a key component
to signal for that.
App health is important for your
search results in the Store.
It's important for the
promotional and merchandising
collections in the store.
App health is also important
for awards designations
and collections, like
editor's choice and the Google
Play Awards.
So getting your
app health right is
one of the most fundamental
things developers
can do to be successful in Play.
Play takes in various
user signals to determine
and app's promotability,
and the app vitals
point directly into that.
For example, if an
app crashes often,
it could lead to a user having
a really poor experience.
They could probably wind up
leaving you a poor review.
You get more one-star ratings.
They could even lead to lower
usage and even uninstalls.
All of this can
negatively impact
your promotability and your
presence in the Play Store.
So developing
high-quality apps actually
acts as a virtuous cycle to
where you have a better user
experience, you're going
to get better user reviews.
Those better user
reviews and ratings
will get you better
results and promotability
within the store, which will
drive more users, et cetera.
The new and updated
Featured Collection,
this has been a
longtime favorite
of our users and developers
in the Play Store.
And frankly, it's a
favorite of the Play team
as well because
it's a great place
to showcase the highest
quality apps and games
that are launching on any
given week in the store.
As you can imagine,
app quality has
been a key foundational
factor when reviewing apps
and determining their
eligibility for consideration
in this collection.
And as you can imagine,
these new app vital metrics
that we're talking
about are going
to plug into this app quality
review that we do on the apps.
And then, finally, we have
the Google Play Awards.
These celebrate the achievements
of our developer community
over the past year by
recognizing the best apps
and games across 12 categories.
This year we've
introduced new categories
to fully reflect the
breadth of apps and games
that deliver innovative
experiences in the Play Store.
We evaluate both the apps
and games on overall design,
on quality, and on
user experience.
And we're now going to be
using the app vital metrics
to inform whether the apps have
a strong technical performance
as well.
As luck would have it, the
Google Play Award ceremony
is happening right after
this session at 6:30 PM
over on stage three,
and you're all invited.
In fact, you're highly
encouraged to join us.
It's a fabulous
celebration of the best
of the best across the
industry and across your peers
over the last year.
So please join us.
I'll turn this back over to
Fergus so he can wrap up.
FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Joe.
So we covered a lot
of things today.
And I hope you're excited
about these 10 secrets,
and that you'll be able to
refer your other coworkers
to our BuzzFeed talk when
it's posted on BuzzFeed later.
Only joking.
No, it won't be
posted on BuzzFeed,
but it will be posted on
YouTube for all your colleagues
to enjoy it.
Please take a photo
of the top secrets
and send it to
your team as well.
And I encourage you
to use these tools
and play around with
the Play Console.
There's a lot of tools in there.
We rebranded the Play Developer
Console as the Play Console
because we realize
that there is--
very valuable to
many stakeholders
in the organizations that
are building applications.
And so please, go ahead,
use the Play Console,
and use the many tools
that we mentioned today
to have success.
We're now going to
open it up to Q&A.
And we'll also be
over at Sandbox Dome C
after this and tomorrow.
So we've got mics here in
the middle of the rows here.
Please come up and ask us
any questions you have.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]